[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
[Music]
welcome back to the always punctual
break room
uh this is the live
show here on new rockstars where we
bring you the the nerd news of the day
live from our very very own break room
yeah here in the new rockstars hq
offices uh coming up on this episode
could use a cappuccino maker just saying
sorry go ahead you keep bringing this up
coming up we're aware are the werewolves
in moonlight how much do people really
know about what caused the blip
how much stranger can stranger things
get and where the hell is vision a
question we've all been asking really um
since we went blind uh with me today are
uh some very special guests now for some
strange reason yeah brandon barrack did
not show up today we haven't heard from
him good riddance i'm not sure what
happened he was here last night working
we can only help yeah you said when you
left he was the last person left in the
building he had that he looked very
worried he was like i was like brandon
do you need help he said only i can stop
this well what i mean why do i want to
do anything i don't know
i don't know when someone says only i
can stop this as a rule of thumb
that's
i can only assume it will find
resolution tomorrow on friday the 13th
but in the meantime we are very lucky
and thrilled to have in his seat uh new
rockstar's own whitney man leaning in
i'm in brandon's seat and it might kill
me yeah she's making me so nervous i am
so scared you guys i've almost died
twice the people the people that are
just listening to the podcast now you
know uh brandon c is broken
since we started simon brandon's seat i
am broken
and uh on equally probably unstable
chairs we've got uh the wonderful
jessica clemens yeah
she's too small for my hips i got big
hips okay i've been saying that since
the beginning of the show and no one's
giving me a hip fitted chair okay well
we'll get to work on that throw throw a
couple bucks in the super chat for the
uh
fun yeah that's right if we get over 2
000 in the super chat today we'll get
new chairs for everybody but if we get
over one thousand dollars just for me
okay
and speaking of uh our
our chair hungry uh third host over here
we got mr tommy back talking i'm feeling
great my ass fit's great on this chair
okay and that's not a swear word it was
born chairman
the chairman of the board uh over here
uh speaking of swears yeah we've we've
got a fun uh contest redemption thing
going on today if we collect a hundred
dollars in super chats it unlocks our
swear jar that's right now the new
rockstar swear jar is the opposite of a
normal swear jar it allows us to swear
we try to keep it clean we don't we try
not to curse on this show but if we hit
100 bucks that unlocks a free swear to
whichever host notices it first yeah uh
heck yeah and they get to have a lot of
fun hell count no no
no yeah because it's a place yeah i
technically yeah
[Applause]
and films here we're towing a very thin
line with this and we're going to cross
into a curse word and i can't wait for
it but i really want a shout out in the
chat someone said big hip gang and i'm
not trying to start a new thread you can
say
i got wide hips
they don't lie either oh maybe you're
slowing down now you've got too many
nicknames you can't beat the security
and the tv i'm the ariana grande of the
break room and everybody knows that he
uh he has a lot of different racist many
embodies okay uh we're gonna she's white
she no but she she's always like she's
dressed
as different things for different
promotional things for videos and it's
problematic you're right are we doing
the show
uh let's jump into some headlines
thank you john
ah you know we're gonna cover all the
big news that you should be hearing
about right now uh top gun maverick is
uh releasing at the end of this month
and it's wild the stuff that's coming
out about this people love this movie
they got their official rotten tomato
score 96 percent oh god
so good my gosh oh wow some would say
that's higher than six uh i almost said
martin luther king again that's higher
than um
what is the what you like paddington no
no
no it's the one that whitney likes uh
the cars are the best in the future yeah
i think it's higher than fast and
furious thousands of years yeah i would
assume right to my god what what right
what face of the fierce is above 50 on
ross
okay
is what audience members put in but
rotten tomatoes is critics and so it's
like that's an incredibly high number
for like what should be a popular well
it also how long has it been out it's
not out it's just it's just it's like
just the screen yeah yeah honestly it
could be a good homage to the original
so let's hope we want it to be a great
moment i only trust i have a neighbor
named theodore and he calls it the
theodore score and i only trust his
reviews now what he does is he shouts
them through my back window at midnight
and he'll just come in and they'll be
like doctor strange didn't love it and
that's how i yeah and sometimes he does
it twice that's why you call him teddy 2
scores that's right
all right more headlines uh we got a new
stranger things poster today packed with
all kinds of cool details and uh some
locations look at whoa
i love it like they're very it's very
much an 80s kind of fantasy horror movie
oh my gosh uh style you can see the los
angeles with the palm trees down at the
bottom
is that big ben
yes i think so it's gonna be some london
action are you guys not tired of seeing
the floating head posters yet no i'm
forever i am so tired a fun fact is that
that is not big ben that is a clock that
has been featured in a ton of the
promotional material for stranger things
so far and what i believe so this is a
pretty wild theory and i will try to be
fast but i think that uh vecna
is a lynch and that oh that's what we
said we said that earlier we said that
on one episode the clock is actually his
i think it's called a phalanx tree i
looked it up hold on okay john's gonna
yell at you if you're gonna make sure
i'm pronouncing it right no i just want
to see if i'm pronouncing it a little
fact checking here folks never hurts
okay
john is screaming get off after i was
right i was right i was right okay
i think that that's his phylactery where
he's housing his soul
and that the kids are going to have to
so that's not true
that's not bad yeah to be fair we don't
know the name of his phylactery he could
be naming it big bang you could name it
it's not the big band but it could be
it could be yeah because you said
specifically it's not big bad and i want
that on record
it's it's not the real like the real one
yes the big london tower it's the
dungeons a grandfather clock sized clock
too it's not a big building right i
think it's little ben okay yeah it's a
little bad
peyton christensen told total film
magazine that the lightsaber fights in
the upcoming kenobi series will more
closely resemble the fights in the
prequel than in the original trilogy
thank god i think we can all agree that
we need more preaching spinning and
leaping and flipping
is better than standing up like two
medieval nights
slowly pressing your lightsabers against
each other or athletic right hey sir
alec guinness was not us a young man god
bless you he already crossed over the
bridge over river kwai seven-year-old
movie reference cry jedi
jedi gang you should start a workout
program called sprite data
i would have to work out
yeah i'm not hitting it
thank you the hairstyles in that workout
program would be wonderful with the with
the braid uh speaking to i o nine bryce
dallas howard said all it would take for
her to direct a star wars film was for
lucasfilm to ask hey
her phone's working she's got a charge
yeah okay just give her a call how would
you guys feel about bryce dallas howard
of course she's directed episodes of
booker boba fett and i believe the
mandalorian season two i think she's a
great and also i think the directing's
in their blood like ron you guys don't
know ron howard's daughter but like i
think it's
yes my name is ron howard just like on
the universal studio in case you guys
don't know ron howard from the freaking
jamie foxx music video blame it on the
alcohol yeah because he's in it re-watch
it ron howard is on the blazer
actually
please
i always just call him ron howard the
guide of the universal studios
he's a man of all he's a man of all
right ron howard hosts part of the
tournament i mean the voice of park uh
of uh arrested development the guy has
done a
director of solo they would be the first
father-daughter
directing star wars tandem
but we're going to come back we've got
some other bryce dallas howard directing
possible news we're going to come back
too uh in an interview with
comicbook.com moon knight writer jeremy
slater revealed that there weren't any
plans to include werewolf by night in
the series however he did pitch the
inclusion of werewolves in general so
not the werewolf by night yes but just
like the idea of werewolves there was
going to be a scene where like moon
knight would fight like a big werewolf
looking creature
um but they didn't do it i think he also
mentioned in that interview
that that they had other plans for
werewolf by night which we are heavily
speculating is the halloween special but
it better be he specifically said it on
the record that like the reason they
were like even when it was brought up
very very preliminary discussions they
were like no there's something else for
him yeah that makes sense you didn't
want to burn a fun character like that
just done like a one-episode kind of
candidate oh great yeah um uh
speaking of slater in the same interview
he revealed that it was jake lockley
that alter who asked out stephen's
co-worker in that one episode oh
i had that video come out a couple weeks
ago where i called that y'all and it's
because
jake is the one who cares about getting
his friend's dick wet he's like look i
gotta take my other altars and i gotta
make sure that they they're they're blue
very careful we don't have any squares
okay i'm not i don't know what not it
might be okay we're gonna save forever
i mean wet dicks are fine over here
that's his fourth personality it's
richard and his personality what richard
and it's his penis yeah i just don't
know why he would do that when he has a
lot of other stuff to be doing
mostly violence i like that he's not
just a one note character he's not just
wrecking shop you know and beating dudes
i mean he's asking out attractive ladies
he's gonna smash and then he's gonna
smash
was it you jessica that pointed out we
only ever heard jake speak spanish yeah
yeah i was like yeah i'm obsessed and
with the fact that in the comics he
wasn't but in this that he is and i we
were trying to figure out but i mean
surely he does after talking about it
with you guys surely he is bilingual
like sure especially after you mentioned
that uh mark and steven have the same
they can steal like each other's
fighting abilities they can probably
still get into the mind of like oh you
speak english also except be really
funny if like the reason why jake
lockley is so mad is because he just has
these two annoying english speakers in
his head all the time
i have no idea what the [ __ ] oh no
honestly he's allowed oh
i said pho but i didn't finish it so
that's right we're safe we're safe we're
safe
look how tortured she is
the same price as your morning coffee
you could put it into our swear jar so
now whitney can you currently i'm so
sorry
in a different interview with the direct
jeremy slater finally answered whether
or not mark spector survived the blip we
kind of speculated right based on like
uh passport dates and things like that
he confirmed that the writer's room
collectively thought he survived the
blip he did not get blipped uh
and uh you know it's just something you
have to deal with as you're writing mcu
practices right you basically have to be
like where were all of these characters
that's the first question i think that
has to be addressed and someone has to
tell us is did they survive the blip or
not yeah we're still in that i think
probably because he was already in egypt
and it's so sandy in the pyramids you
guys they were like this guy can't
handle it he can't break down
and sam he can't dust and stand at the
same time that's crazy you know what i
don't want that
the same jeremy slater uh which i often
forget he wrote the josh trank fantastic
four movie that's right well he did yes
well he wrote it he wrote a very early
draft a draft the one that michael b
jordan and um what's his name my best
friend miles teller jeremy slater jeremy
slater or moon knight yes okay that's
interesting he also wrote that film uh
and of course because he's doing the
rounds right now and because it's in the
news they asked him about john krasinski
uh showing up in
as reed richards in multiverse madness
uh and and of course he endorsed it
because why wouldn't you he was like i
think brzezinski is a really cool choice
and that's who they go with for whoever
the real version of reed is when that
gets introduced um by the way we got
kind of half reamed we did put um
john krasinski's rude richards in the
thumbnail for yesterday's break room a
lot of folks did not enjoy that they
thought of it as a spoiler even though
you know the movie and maybe we take for
granted we've all seen the movie yeah
multiple times at this point yeah some
folks have not some countries have not
gotten the movie that's the main why i
would apologize so i would and this is
always this is an eric vos style counter
argument how do you know that's a
spoiler if you haven't seen the movie
yet good point what do you mean alright
you got it i didn't know that's the
support
image there's a million of those fan
images out there that's right people
have been photoshopping uh krasinski's
reed richards for years can i say
something yes i think
john kozinski
is thirstier than a dog on a 90 degree
day to play reed richards and nothing
nothing would make me laugh harder sorry
no you're good then if they cast someone
else in the six one second it's not his
fault it's not his fault that the fans
were the ones that started it are you
saying that wouldn't be a little good
news
[Music]
i wanted a little good i wanted john
krasinski to play mr fantastic so bad
everybody wants him to including him
yeah when the fans made the art of it
and started going with it i was like i
abide by this i was like go ahead let
him play mr fantastic i think he's a
cute fantastic i think he's fine i'm
just kidding i love the office i love
him but i i just also think it's funny
that when like amateur or up-and-coming
actors advocate for themselves for roles
and do like film themselves in the
costume and they're like could you
imagine we all kind of scoff and laugh
but when a mega star is like i gotta
play this role we're like yes dad i mean
you must i didn't work out for lou
he kind of pulled that it worked out for
the guy that played aladdin all right so
it's worked out twice hasn't worked out
nine million times but you're right
you're right it is like okay he's plus
he's not suffering for work right now
he's making a lot of movies i will say i
am extra on board if they get emily
blunt to play sue storm i by the way i'm
kidding i'm fine with him playing reed
richards and if emily blunt plays sue
storm his kids can play the the kids
dude tommy is backpedaling so hard we
know you hate johnson that's not true
john and i are good friends you guys go
way back guy and i and miles teller all
hang out yeah yeah speaking of fantastic
four news
um
that projects the development and some
producers are signed on and it's the
moon night duo of grant curtis and nick
pepin which you know i don't know and
pepin sorry
salt peppers
but uh curtis and pepe don't let zach
ever do that again sorry uh
even that tiny snippet i'm off rhythm
but
and now i don't know it's it's pretty uh
deep inside baseball to follow producer
careers yeah but clearly like marvel has
folks they like and then they keep uh
assigning themselves and in fact there
are people signed on means like oh this
project's moving forward yes i think
that's the thing and i i will say and we
we gotta we we gotta get our own graphic
for this one this is a rumor i wanna be
clear this is a rumbling and a rumor
okay a grumbling if you will it's a
groomer wait it's a groomer it's a
grumbling it's a better it's a grumbling
it's a groomer uh supposedly no no it's
not no you said groomer a groomer
no
not that kind of a
no no with a u with a u
it's group it's about group
sorry
portmanteaus can get you into trouble
but there's a rumor that bryce dallas
howard might be in line to direct this
fantastic oh
i love it
i think she's been doing great like
every time her name randomly shows up as
like the director for any because it's
not only the book of boba fett she's
done other ones that i don't know them
all the time my head but i'll be
watching something it'll say like
directed by bryce dallas tower and i'm
like she's doing it she's going off and
also
directors are great actors as directors
can also be really phenomenal just
because they're directing clearly the
actors at where they need to go and i
would say just to go to the original uh
meat of that headline like yeah producer
information maybe isn't the most
riveting but though they're kind of
shepherding the show and the way that
moon knight was received
i think people want more of that tone
and more like if they can bring
you know fantastic four is kind of a
whimsical like i mean it's like the old
fantastic four is almost kind of like a
like a hannah barbara cartoon like
stretch they turn invisible there's the
thing so if they can maybe make that a
little more intense grounded yeah well
and and you know there's a lot to both
producing films and directing films
right beyond just like what shows up on
screen right like maybe these people are
like great to work with maybe they like
stick to a budget they show up on time
and they're nice folks and that's why
disney wants to keep working with them
also oh they have a fun time and they're
nice they're not drunk
they don't yell they're not tommy i mean
no
i always show up on time what are you
talking about i was the first one here
today
i don't sleep here because i don't sleep
you'll sleep when you're dead i was
saying i'm okay with oh god i'm okay
with everything with a fantastic four as
long as they put dr doom in it
eventually and that doctor doom is keanu
reeves oh here he is
hot take true
uh maybe it should be john krasinski
murphy's multiverse michael waldron
teased the multiverse as the major
current threat in the mcu saying whether
it's kang or incursions the mcu is
setting up uh major multiversal threats
on the board um
yeah i got news for you guys i want
whitney to take this but we've got to
swear
[ __ ] we've got a sn
wow selfish selfish jessica didn't let
our guests swear it's okay i think we
can equally all swear no it's one swear
guys remember we agree
we said the entire time no we'll just
raise another hundred dollars like
nothing don't worry that's all right
crazy you know what i i like that
jessica like hey if somebody
you know if somebody sticks out their
finger you said it's not my fault
you reached and i said [ __ ]
oh well i said it again
well okay well that one now we're back
in the hole yeah now we're negative one
so now we're gonna make 200 more dollars
oh [ __ ]
oh no
now we're gonna make three i don't know
you guys got it you guys got it
regardless you guys got it regardless
guys i'm so sorry i'm on i have two
strikes if i get a third strike you're a
punishment don't put me away for life
you're a punishment whitney is you have
to give me that okay
okay now it's mine
i think it's a good thing to include a
distracting visual thing during the show
speaking of visuals uh we've got some
new images from miss marvel's uh
from the marvel twitter account let's
see it's marvel series look at that oh
oh this is at the this is the i do we
know what this scene is we're guessing
it's like a cosplay thing i thought it
was a convention yes um punching through
either that or it's like roger's the
musical okay yeah
she just fell on stage
some of these are very similar to ones
we've seen yeah
oh that guy is a hat that's nice do you
know that guy with the hat whitney i
don't know
do we know when it premieres again it's
coming it's in june it's coming like
next month yeah we're gonna have kenobi
and miss marvel kenobi and miss marvel
are gonna be going at the same time
we're going to uh we're going to be
driven insane here at new rochester
craziest thing um but speaking of miss
marvel
like kill myself you guys that sounds
like my nightmare if uh if everybody on
camera starts appearing with giant bags
under their eyes and yeah lost the will
to live you'll know it's because there's
two disney plus series at the same time
can't always just be me zach
speaking of miss marvel in an interview
with entertainment weekly uh the miss
marvel producer sana i'm a not apologies
i'm sure i butchered that explain how uh
captain marvel's fight with thanos
affects kamala khan
okay and uh here's a there's a good
quote what's unique is captain marvel is
one of the few really well-known big
time female avengers if you will she had
a pretty significant save in the battle
against thanos i think if someone who is
young and looking out at the world and
she sees this really powerful badass
woman almost take down thanos what does
that do to you how do you internalize
that right basically
the quote kind of goes on kamala khan
drew inspiration from this but it got us
thinking right that's a battle that took
place on another planet right nobody was
live streaming that battle and yet lots
of characters including this upcoming
character seem to be very aware of what
took place in that battle right how do
you think people know
the thing is i would i was talking to
john about this i i really
and agree to disagree i was really
irritated that we're like acknowledging
that like civilians know everything like
in doctor strange how he was straight up
like
you could have done a lot of things like
how do you know he had like fourteen
hundred like ideas dr west sits down
next to us doctor strange at christine's
wedding yeah at the wedding i was so
frustrated i was like they shouldn't
know that much but i think it's kind of
hard to keep that bottled up there's
there was a lot of superheroes involved
with it and they're probably talking to
families we talked to friends who talked
talk talk a ton of people in general
were involved in that because you had
like the whole like army from wakanda
you had
like you had like all of these like
space armies all of the sorcerers the
sorcerers from commerce
that's just a lot of people to know
something and like the more people know
a secret the less of a secret that thing
is yeah and i think also the way these
things historically like you know if we
take like real life examples they get
retold
differently by everyone who was here
so like there's probably so much
half true information about this battle
made by like people who are big like
thor
people who worship thor as a god are
like what was thor the character
i think i earlier said this battle was
on another planet thinking of the
infinity war battle but of course the
end game battle was fought on earth that
was all right again not with live news
crews reporting and nobody had their
cell phone camera out but anderson
cooper didn't make it to the site to
report a lot unfortunately how do we
know he didn't maybe he just wasn't in
the movie maybe he wasn't on camera but
maybe he was out there doing the lord's
work that's true dodging chatari you
know projectiles or whatever um i will
say
you know i think like it was purposeful
in in multiverse of madness that the 828
reality they lied to people about how
they defeated thanos right
to
to make i think
thank you
every time okay that is a ticket it's
not
thank you tommy thank you i'm not
calling you zaddy anymore i'm gonna call
you i might call it eight one eight the
valley baby
johnny till i die
enjoy it
rest in peace
um but uh well i i think like that was
instructive right that is a reality
where they lied to their people about
what happened as opposed to in the 616
reality it seems like everybody knows
the actual truth yeah sure well it's
also like
going back to a time he said following
like real
life situations you're gonna have to
tell the public the truth about some
stuff you can't you cannot be like oh
yeah it was just another
no it attacked all of us and i think
also kind of like watchmen the original
watchmen is fighting a common fight
we'll have the world work together to
defeat it
and let's not forget uh eric voss our
good friend uh cued us up uh airfox
our dear friend and our co-worker on
this channel who definitely knows all of
our names
and
uh is is a good friend of ours as i said
he reminded all of us on the slack today
that in far from home one of the
in-flight movie options was a
documentary about oh
so we're making media about this whole
thing oh my god as directed documentary
green grass that's right he pointed out
so it might be a flight 93 uh style oh
yeah
people they should do they should do a
documentary on the make it that one kid
that wrote flashpoint oh yeah like
wow yeah all right speaking of
documentaries i'm about to introduce you
guys to the greatest documentary of this
year that was when i did a hello
freshman yeah all right we want to do a
big thanks to hellofresh helping us out
today uh or helping us out all week
helping us out as a sponsor in general
bringing you this episode today get
yourself some farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients seasonal recipes delivered
right to your doorstep hit me on camera
three i'm talking straight into your
baby i'm not looking at this camera
anymore i pulled a fastball on you john
recipes the wreck your door with hello
fresh they make home cooking fun and
easy and what i like affordable now
here's some great footage of me making a
gorgeous
sweet chili pork ball look at those
vegetables oh he said i don't need a
cutting board
move them here's me pouring the rice in
there's the pork look at that smoke and
sizzle utilizing that green
and there's the final product that sweet
sweet steam rising up next to my two
dollar aviator glasses steaming up the
lens you can see my face in the
background that's an easter egg for you
all right
pick uh hand me back over there
pick your favorites for 50 different
weekly options okay
why is that annoying it's called
directing from the child i love you you
know i love you get her out you're too
critical today okay
you're just being mean
all right no there's a feud on the break
room hashtag break room breakup
hashtag just two mean tom too sensitive
all right camera three pick your
favorites from 50 different weekly
options and skip weeks when you need to
change your delivery date or update your
preferences on on the hellofresh app
you'll be eating hella fresh this oh
sorry roll that back we can it's a live
show we'll be eating hellofresh this
week and you should do you're just
focusing on jess now she's loving this
go to hellofresh.com breakroom16 and use
codebreakroom16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts and i'm going to
give you one free gift now people aren't
perfect
okay did you make mistakes stop
switching cameras man was created as an
imperfect being by my lord and savior
patrick swayze all right now we want to
talk about another cool thing zach what
do you got over there look at it
we're we're uh uh showing folks our our
our new latest obsession
uh shirt available at
newrockstarsmerch.com this one's
inspired by multiverse of madness it's
called shattered madness
shattered madden is also one of the one
of my favorite air metal uh bands but um
uh you could pick that up along with the
cool shirt i've got on yes nobody else
is wearing their new rockstars merch but
you don't see them on camera all the
time yeah we love our merch new
rockstarsmerch.com that directly helps
support our channel and this show along
with uh using that hello fresh code um
now uh shouting at
jessica clements does not help support
our channel at all but but i do want a
poll of uh
am i too mean or is tommy too sensitive
or which one is it or both of them just
gucci too much that's right
maybe we need to take this show from
zero to de niro oh gotta hear it guys
all right now it looks like the poll is
overwhelmingly a resounding success i
was elected by a margin of 66 to 33 as a
personal cook for our viewers you would
allow you would eat what i cooked let me
tell you the reviews i got on what i
cooked my girlfriend and her mom both
ate it and this is what they said
oh okay
so if you want meals that make you go
oh okay
let me cook for you and you know
what get that yellow fresh out of the
corner john
yeah this is no longer an ad for them
because let me tell you something if i
made something edible you know hello
fresh is easy to do because i can't even
make toast without almost burning the
house down now
eating my hello fresh meals are not
mandatory but you know what it's
mandatory around here mandatory fun god
dang it
oh it's time for mandatory fun the
segment that makes everybody go oh okay
okay uh it's so nice we like to play the
graphic twice here hit that graphic
again
that was the nicest way you've ever
asked for the second time all right
in honor of the creepy ice cream song
billy and tommy sang in multiverse of
madness how did it go i scream
something something you know what's
funny it's almost erased on the internet
i was looking for the lyrics for it it's
hard to find i wonder if they're getting
a lot of ice cream backlash and they're
scrubbing and rubbing even though in the
credits right it's credited to danny
elfman and michael waldron i allegedly
wrote that which i think you know dang
well michael waldron wrote it
in under 20 seconds i hope yeah
what if it sounded much better and then
once the kid's saying it danny elfman
was like they're ruining
myself
when i wrote this song no no no i'm not
saying oh i thought you meant mandatory
i've really got you shook now jess maybe
this is a lesson learned that when you
yell at people you created abusive
atmosphere oh the polls up we've got uh
jess is mean at 40 and tommy's too
sensitive at 60. all right so what do we
know about me i'm sensitive and i like
to cook
speaking of alternate personalities
getting dicks wet oh my god
all right
okay so in honor of the ice cream song
billy and tommy sang and multi voice of
madness i've asked all three of you
today to write a fun snack based jingle
for me tom to maximoff okay i'm gonna go
first
but one of them's name is literally
tommy yeah
and i will not take any more questions
or criticism today on the show
specifically from the left side
all right
i will start our songs
oh my gosh all right put it in the poll
would you rather be tom domestic or
tommy maxwell since everything's got to
be data driven today all right guys vote
now also i just i just want to let it be
known uh time we did uh forewarn us
about this mandatory fund but he didn't
tell us he was gonna write a page full
of lyrics for himself yeah no i thought
we were each doing like a quick bar
he said two lines arrived i said do two
lines of rhyme and then i wrote my song
guys i don't make the rules yes yes you
do you're interested
you know what i won't do mine today
why don't you go first since evidently i
worked too hard on this today
my god i'm under attack you're being a
very
[Laughter]
[Applause]
by fire look at two tondas from my
friend caleb campbell all right
sometimes life gives you a pause that's
when i reach for veggie straws sea salt
is my favorite
flavor
but life is such a twisted dance and all
that's left was zesty ranch now that's
the only taste i savor
oh veggie straws you know i really love
you veggie straws there's no one else
above you veggie straws i give my soul
to you
[Music]
know there's more greek veggie straws
take my firstborn lovely veggie straws
you aren't made with any corn veggies
straws i swear my allegiance to your
dark mystery except my blood as eternal
sacrifice
i am minion i am soldier i am
veggie
strong
the people working in the office next to
us are so well
also this is going to be the most
anticlimactic bit in the history of
antec like back to events you just did
all of that and i'm going to half
improvise a two-line song all right
who's next that was incredible well i
will go just to cleanse the palette
before whitney and jessica have to go uh
my my uh
sonnet here is about
quaker uh rice crisps these have been a
delight in the new stars uh break room
and kitchen
and so this is my bad off-key
uh billy and tommy esque song um
i like myself
like a good boy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when i'm eating rice not like
someone in the chat just said zaddy
[Laughter]
oh that was beautiful
i'm crying oh my god you broke
okay tom de maximov is very pleased my
children oh wow oh tom loves you all all
right whitney what do you got for us
um i'm sure [ __ ] well i know i know
first of all i didn't know that the food
had to be physically present either oh
and only if it's available readily in
our breakfast no you gave me cupcakes
and i and now i want one um
so this is gonna be and it's right now
it's happening right now i'm gonna sing
you a little song that i'm making up
this minute great okay here we go
okay so good and sweet
i like to eat them with my feet
i squish my toes in the frosting
oh my god
and that is why today i sing oh
wonderful rhyming
there's a little vibrato in that voice
too and that was kind of nice i got to
be honest
both of you were insecure about your
songs
i think that both of you took more time
in making those songs up then stupid
billy or tommy did he's singing the dumb
ice cream song
but you know what they're child actors
which means like intellectually they're
40.
right
that's actually true all right jess
bring us home that means like dakota
fanning's like a hundred yeah she's oh
she's a little alien she's timeless no
she's dying she is all right my turn
she's hurting all right
twilight i'm going to sing my song about
the pizza balls
from
oh from multiverse madness because they
were
meaningful to me okay um
mom
may i have some pizza balls
you know from the pizza papa
[Music]
he's not
gonna be there all day
so you gotta make some time for pizza
papa cause he
oh
and birthday party style napkins
silverware uh don't want to say it don't
want to say it but i'm going to empty's
birthdays tomorrow
happy birthday happy 59th jessica made
actual
stuff
pizza balls wow good are they good look
at that wow their pizza their pizzas
their pizza their pizza and you know
what uh
they're they're much cheaper than the
eight to eight yeah
well technically for you guys they're
free
oh yeah we didn't get a price yeah we
don't know what their currency system is
you want me to tweet out bruce campbell
yeah yeah
please how much money was owed to you
sir
now um
you know the the rest of the show is
mandatory fun is over by the way
and everyone did a great job mandatory
snack yes
uh we're gonna have move on here um
uh
with um today's break room breakdown
yeah
so let me finish chewing my mouth
this was a horrible idea
well
we did agree we were gonna do it it's
very i will say before we get started
they're very simple to make i the tick
tock that i posted on my twitter account
is actually the recipe that i used um
the only
extra little knot i will tell you guys
to do is it's easier to make it with
your own pizza dough because if you buy
store-bought pizza dough it's kind of
hard to mold into a bowl but if you make
your own it's easier to like press your
thumb into put sauce mozzarella fold
into a ball put it in a
cupcake tin put in the oven 400 for only
eight to ten minutes you guys and you
got it and you just put more cheese and
sauce on top it's basically it's a pizza
i gotta say this is probably not the
content you clicked on the thumbnail for
but
you know you know you're never gonna get
a taste testing and a breakdown that's
right empty is not it's not sampling
in a theory video we need both eric and
mt intravenously anyway they don't allow
it in the blue that's right there's no
food no water no warmth yeah comfort no
comfort no hope so let's go let's get
into the break room break round today on
the break room breakdown we are going to
figure out where the hell vision went
when i'm talking vision i'm also talking
white vision
um also mainly white vision is during
multivisor madness plus continue
debating whether or not wanda is really
dead because we've been getting a lot of
questions we've talked about it but now
we have our key source whitney van
landingham on to talk about it uh can we
play that break room can we put a break
room can we play the clip
are we really that surprised he never
checked in on wanda as the darkhold
corrupted her in that cabin in one of
vision episode nine the synthezoid tried
to give wand to the black bolt treatment
and i was told you were powerful
now yes hex vision unlocked his memories
but white vision seemed more in a place
of self-discovery than love for wanda as
an easily malleable synthesiod you make
a pretty fun target for agatha harkness
and heck of the house of harkness who
think about it now that 616 wanda seems
to be gone and the dark hole is
destroyed agatha might be liberated from
that hex that wanda left to run kill me
soon all right okay so
so that was the clip sorry you guys
while we were shoveling our face with
some more pizza balls so that's the clip
that boss did and
we
don't all necessarily agree with the
fact whitney had a theory so i i don't
want to spoil whitney's video that's
coming out clearly so we're not going to
get too into it but i do spoil it i'll
just read the whole thing from
everything
and you can watch it again tomorrow
but when you were saying that once you
die the spell dies with you or it
doesn't die no it doesn't so as we
learned in um i forget if it was
infinity war end game whenever um
uh doctor strange was talking to thanos
and thanos was like give me the stone or
i'll kill you and then take it off of
you and he was like oh i think you'll
find that you cannot easily break a dead
man's spell so if the scarlet witch
is dead
just because she's dead wouldn't mean
that the spell broke and released agatha
oh so agatha would still be in the under
the spell yeah he's technically yeah she
would typically still be even if one of
the dead and if one is still alive then
yeah definitely she's still under the
spell so i think that no matter what
he's under the spell still do you think
white vision can break that though then
yes i do oh did you talk about this in
your video i don't talk about this
but yeah i know no this is this is just
my theory from right now in general i
heard eric's clip and i was like don't
agree don't agree we when we do the
breaking breakdown uh nine times out of
ten we don't agree with what boss said
but you know what people do agree with
me tom de maximoff blew tommy maximoff
out of the water what was the poll was
the numbers 64 percent 64th damn
damn oh sorry i will say you also won
the poll of who had the best bop usually
the best snack jingle um with almost 35
percent of the vote i got 24. that's
pretty good it's a clean sweep i'm the
most sensitive i'm putting my feet in
foods no i am not that's right well
yours is going to be the most isolated
clip by weirdos
and i made it just for i put a youtube
video of whitney talking about her feet
for an hour
that's just me by the way i'm doing an
impression once they start like letting
you post reels to wiki feed it's over
for oh my god jesus christ so vision
could technically white vision i love
the idea of white vision coming back to
what east view and it becoming now white
vision and agatha instead of normal
vision and wanda oh that'd be cool um
but i i would also like that because if
wanda's spell is still casted on agatha
don't you think seeing vision would take
her out of it right am i is that too
cartoony two
cinderella happen no i think that's how
i'd react i like your point
no don't you think that's a pretty
weak sauce
it's weak whole to put in her spell that
if a certain person comes across you
that will break the spell i think it's
definitely a weak saucy spell but i
think it's definitely you know it's not
a weak sauce the size you put on these
yeah that's exactly what is that
delicious is that from scratch
scratch no i bought it from the jar and
i just add a bunch of extra seasonings
because i was irritated yeah um
i think it is a wiki sauce kind of
situation but it's just like
vision and her kids meant so much to her
don't you think that's like something
like when you're casting a spell you're
not trying to think about because you're
like it'll take me out of my spell um
also will you scroll up really quick i
did want to touch on uh
so vision 838 is alive as proven by
proven by ultron centuries uh who only
come about as a response to visions
creation well they come about because of
the ultron
uh
you know
project oh yeah right like
which also had vision as a kind of a
byproduct of that yeah we could assume
that yeah he probably exists though he
wasn't invisible in the battle against
thanos not a part of the illuminati not
showing up anywhere and you're not a
great illuminati member so ultron exists
in 838 but not vision well that's what
it seems well i don't know though
because
um in interviews um elizabeth olsen
talks about that he does exist they're
just not together they're divorced or
whatever yeah they're like yeah that's
what she was just chronically i feel
like vision and i are like divorced and
i'm like yeah girl
got to figure out a way to get to that
universe but then once there let's go um
i also like at least in in the the
comics right the illuminati was all
these figureheads that represented
larger groups of heroes right obviously
professor x represents the x-men right
like black bolt represents the inhumans
right so like maybe captain carter there
as representing avengers i think so it's
not that the illuminati are the only
heroes on that in that universe
hopefully there are others well they
refer to her as captain carter the first
avenger right she's introduced to that
so that doesn't imply there are a second
a third a fourth avenger yes at least
four i say guy be at least and they're
all magicians from las vegas
no you guys i'm not trying to pitch
something but when rogue theory comes
out this week which is normally on
fridays yes tomorrow yeah tomorrow the
rogue theory where me and whitney have
this great theory about the las vegas
magicians and how they are a different
universe las vegas avengers they're the
last they're the
if you think it sounds weird you're
guessing the same way same with why i
brought up martin luther king earlier
because i talked about him a lot
eight three eight just a day job night
job kind of a situation i think in in in
universe 547
the vegas magicians are all sorcerer
supremes or sorcerer
trainees don't you think um that's true
i i like as we're getting speculative it
makes me want to go to the the the super
chats here because we've got some good
ones we do uh nash senate
had a fun one uh hello uh from our
friend from the frozen north up in
canada some people are saying uh
illuminati members can be brought back
by using the time stone how convenient
wow
yeah but they if they bring them back
that way
right like that would bring wanda back
too would it not oh well i think you
choose who you bring back is that what
you're talking about oh
i thought the time zone rewinds time oh
oh oh there's a time stone sorry yeah
and it lets you like travel to places
right they're like please listen i'm
happy
in theory we didn't get confirmation
that the infinity stones were destroyed
in that universe yeah maybe they could
be harnessed in some way i like what
brandon was saying how in the comics
they each got each member of the
illuminati well no they don't exist but
the each illuminati member had the stone
right yes so then even though they're
dead it's like where are those stones
now and even eight three eight right
illuminati's are like shark teeth one
dies there's another one ready to step
up right we can only ass hundreds uh
our great friend and and chat moderator
chrissy
coming through always got great facts
thank you chrissy thor and loki are
advanced alien beings that were elevated
to their godly status by their people oh
gods are only gods because of their
worshippers yep we only hold the power
we give them not mine my god's an
awesome god he reigns in heaven
i think
we have another moderator free girl who
is always very supportive of the show my
girl she says please say uh and then she
has a line i think each one of us should
take a stab at the line she wants us to
say where is it i can't see uh it's the
second one down and we truly live in a
golden age of nerds okay that's gonna
deliver that like maybe as the real test
being you are tommy yes oh and then i'll
do it
we truly live
in a golden age of nerds oh number two
camera good work
wait truly
okay
um actually we truly live in a golden
age
very nerdy nice nice
we truly live in a golden age wow
[Applause]
um frankie rodriguez says i really like
when marvel does different feels in
their movies uh i like fantastic four or
i think fantastic four could make great
found footage oh that would be easy
those are two different thoughts frankie
and i like both of them different feels
yeah you want to cheer you want to cry
you want to love you want to laugh oh my
god you want to get real scared when
wanda pops out of the shadows
[Music]
michael hitchcock's phone is charged and
ready
um uh
muddy bear love the name uh from uh
looks like he's from jolly old england
over there do you think it's possible
that the fantastic four brought avengers
tower i think that's meant to be bought
avengers tower in the sixties no i think
the universe oh bot
easter eggs in uh uh spider-man far from
home right coming soon one two three
four and
the baxter building had construction
going on yeah let's hope so right
i i do think marvel will not confirm
that until the fantastic movie starts
yes you know what i mean because they
won't want to set it up and then not be
able to deliver so probably wait till
they deliver but i think you're on to
something
um oh my god they want you to do our two
again jess i don't want to make you
because we've been at war this whole
episode pinned it on my twitter but also
i will do it here today all right
wait can i wait
yeah move
it never gets old i'll never not want it
to happen it might be a slight you know
pizza balls don't
help the delivery per se
but it's not hurting it either um uh i
like uh ron sortino random mcu question
could pimtec be used to shrink the
corpse of tiamat that gigantic
celestial that's halfway sticking out of
the ocean that's actually
is there a limit that we've seen so far
to how well there is there is a limit
because there's a limit to how big
ant-man can get but how much of that is
his biology that is true
the limit does not exist
the limit does not exist
little mean girls i know mean girls well
you know maybe yes and once in a while
no
no all right
i just want people to like me i like
that um marc ass twain
i love that they made me laugh love the
name
says i can't see where it went
uh mark gaston
wait where'd he go where are you oh okay
here i can read it uh rocket raccoon was
a rat before experimentation
that was the secret easter egg in
guardians of the galaxy oh
mark ashton with a little chaos oh whoa
kevin williams gave us a hundred dollars
thanks for getting him and now we can
basically swear twice so
thank you first of all kevin williams
that was very generous wait he said he
they want us to do something specific
can each of you give me visions pickup
line if you went online dating after
being separated from wanda give me that
words encouragement
838 wanda and vision are separated
vision's at a bar maybe a pickup event
maybe he's online this is the the text
he sends what is vision's pickup okay i
got to get one i got one
i might have the vision to see through
walls and doors but [ __ ]
it's for you oh my god
oh my god i'm swooning nice yeah vision
is that you
is that you go next i'm still thinking
i'm thinking too i'm thinking okay okay
i've got i've got a real stinker cooked
up here
um
and and i am terrible at accents so i'm
not gonna be able to do a decent pull
bet anymore i'll try to do a pull bet
you know my
microprocessors can get through
10 billion
tabulations in one microsecond but with
you
i'm going to take my time
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why they call you zaddy in the
chat
mine's not gonna be half as good as that
um we're allowed to curse right
yes encouraged to curse it's encouraging
paul bettany
uh would probably say something along
the words of he's hitting on someone
right he's texting him yes this is
pickup
how about a a bit of caulk
wow by the way this is vision not paul
bentley
very happily married with children to
jennifer connolly so yes i like that
that's just nothing like that i love the
world the world's smartest computer he's
like i'm just going to say it okay
you like these pizza balls when you see
the meat that comes out
papa vision papa always gets paid his
and papa always gets laid yeah
that's how that works
you want to take us home yeah
are you dead
are you dead confirmed
confirmed jessica confirmed
oh my god
take me home i want to leave
what are queefs if not love persevere oh
my god whoa
what a pick up one well i'll tell you
what it is whoever
vision's newest love interest doesn't
run out of the restaurant
if you two were vision i'd be on top of
it
vision i think i'll leave you with that
i think that we're the creepy vision we
do not want to go out it's on that note
i think we wrap up this episode uh again
i uh whenever you clicked on this uh
thumbnail thinking you were gonna get
you got you got taste tests of fictional
uh food made real that's right you got a
filthy worded uh
superhero pickup line i'm just really
glad that before we went live i sent my
uncle joe a detailed explanation of how
to watch the show and god i hope he got
involved cause i would hate him to be
missing any of this hello uncle joe i
hope you enjoyed the show shout out
uncle joe thank you to everybody
in the chat including all those uh fine
folks sending a super chat to try to get
to more of those and i just threw up the
[ __ ] okay oh no well stop
it i'm doing this all right i'm doing it
right now none of these and i gotta say
um we've got one more episode left this
week thank you to everybody that's been
watching this week they are obsessed
with zach uh sorry they're saying zach's
the winner is that
uh but uh um
we tomorrow's a friday the 13th episode
and we are determined to get to the
bottom of what's happened to brandon we
we're kind of concerned yeah we don't
know
i mean the very ominous only i can stop
this what does that even mean i don't
know and and you've been hearing noises
in the building i've been here late i'm
a bit of a workaholic you know you guys
usually leave around 4 45. i'm here
until 9 10 o'clock and there's been just
like i said i found that pair of work
boots but last night i saw a glove
literally had blood on it
very strange why haven't you called the
cops yet well i mean bloody well
did you just say as a bills fam i know a
lot about yeah yeah well our hall of
fame running back o.j i know still in
the ring of honor by the way okay and
off that go bills go thank you so much
windy van lane again for joining us
and thank you everybody we'll be back
tomorrow in the break room
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
true
[Music]
you